so one last thing to do before we go on
to the next lesson is to add the tests
for the functionality that we added in
this lesson the end of the profile
lesson you added the test full profile
so now you need to add the test for
conference that'll be the conference
test class and you can find that in the
lesson 4 folder and also go back into
your conference API class and uncomment
the tests that should work now that
you've added conferences so let's have a
quick look at conference test it always
sets up the values that you're going to
need to test on great the service test
helper which is needed the setup method
which just gets everything ready for the
tests the teardown method cleans up and
then there's just a bunch of different
functions to test the different things
that we've added so test creating a
conference without a name that's not
allowed just creating a conference
anyway so on you can read through the
test files and see what all the things a
test did feel free to add your own tests
and then when you run your project with
maven it will automatically include the
test and we'll run the test and it
actually won't let you run your project
until the tests are successful if you
really get stuck with the test and you
do want to deploy without running the
tests you can choose run as and then run
configurations and then you could create
a configuration and actually enable the
skip tests I don't recommend this it's a
good idea to always test what you're
doing but it is good to know that if you
you know that you can do that if you
need to anyway go ahead and add the
tests to your application and then it's
time for the next lesson